this morning we're talking with a rising
star in what's being called a new golden
era for stand-up comedy you've got
legends like jerry seinfeld and steve
martin going on tour again and newer
stars like trevor noah you know him ali
wong and hassan minaj meanwhile netflix
is dropping specials all the time
several new ones in just the last few
weeks including that divisive hour from
dave chappelle
but amid all of that one of the hottest
tickets around is for a guy named nate
bargetsi we met him on tour in his
hometown of nashville and i'll tell you
his jokes are clean politics free even
weirdly comforting and that is exactly
what a lot of people crave right now
so this is a place you come to a lot
yeah a guy walks into a coffee shop
doesn't sound like much of a setup just
iced coffee with
a cream but for a comedian like nate
bargetsi the smaller the moment the
better the joke i went into starbucks
ordered uh iced coffee with milk nothing
crazy you know and the guy like looked
at me weird you know like when you're
like
get something in your head you're like
i'm pretty sure he doesn't know what i
said the story of another caffeine run
got a big laugh for bargetse in the 2017
netflix show the standups and he gives
me milk with ice in it
that's i had to ask him i go what is
that he goes milk with ice in it
i was like what do you think do i look
like a psycho do you do it helped launch
the 42 year old comedian into two more
hour-long specials on netflix i take my
shirt off standing there no shirt and
this old man
walks up and goes olivia and his shows
don't really feel like shows at all i
don't know who he disrespected more me
or olivia to be honest i mean
it's almost like two guys waiting for
their kids practice to finish so they
can go home and have dinner it's like
just killing time almost yeah but in a
funny way sometimes people come up and
they're like you remind me of like my
brother or my cousin or my something and
like i always remember thinking like
that's what i think i want to be like
you want to be
someone they remind you you know almost
like they're like you're a familiar face
that they can hang out with and while
many of the biggest names in comedy tell
jokes that may be divisive or mean
bargetsi does neither you know as long
as i make fun of myself and my family
i'll be the dumb one and you can either
laugh i look at you laughing with me or
you laugh at me it doesn't even matter
but it's it's about me it's not about
you
i've had three concussions in my life
and none of them because of sports
just just living life man you know
stuff happens to your head what are you
gonna do
and politics is strictly off limits
that's not what i'm here for like
there's a lot of trust
that i that these audiences have in me
and so i don't want to break that trust
the atlantic magazine recently took note
calling him the nicest man in standup
adding he comes across as a walking
xanax a reputation he's built one pg
joke at a time since he first took the
stage nearly 20 years ago here at
zaney's in nashville when you were
figuring it out
did you try on other
styles other kind of tones
no i kind of stayed this way i'm clean
i've always been clean i can only do
this accent i can't not do it so i could
never like tone it down folks here seem
to like his tone just the way it is i
didn't think of this like that this
would come his picture is even painted
on the wall outside this hometown club a
messy crash scene at nashville's most
popular comedy club though his face was
the only face obliterated by a dump
truck last year i was just demolished
nothing though can take away this
accomplishment
bargetsi recently headlined a sold
sold-out show at the grand old opry if
you're a chart maker this has been your
time
you're probably doing graphs too like
you probably like usually i just do
charts but during covet i got pulled
into the graph world quite a bit it
marked a return to the place he once
worked as a teenager sweeping up after
the crowds did you ever look up at the
grand old opry and think to myself
going to be there
it's such a legendary place that i don't
even know if i thought
if i ever it's it's like too far beyond
your dreams and now you you think in the
reverse you know if it doesn't go well
up there you can always come back and
i think they're gonna make me sweep
after the show
part of the deal but making people laugh
has always come naturally to nate
perhaps because it runs in the family
his father stephen was a clown i was
born he was a clown it was never weird
to me i thought everybody's dad was a
clown
i remember his first joke his first joke
this guy's sitting there and he goes
waiter there's a fly in my soup
and the waiter goes don't worry the
spider on the spoon will get it
and nathan laughed i mean we're like
tears coming down his eyes he's laughing
at this joke he's five and a half years
old then he explains to me why it's
funny he said don't you this is what
makes that such a great funny joke
and i mean it didn't but a light should
have come on right then what kid thinks
about why something's funny
on the night we visited dad was also one
of the opening ads it's got to be
elmore's glue okay a little goofiness
followed by a lot of hearts i'm just so
proud of my family
and i had to follow him doing good and
then it's emotional
and then i got to go up and like get and
i got to dig myself out of that hole
i mean you cry because he's your son but
also because
he's doing what you once wanted to do
yeah yeah that's very very very true do
you have a theory for why nate seems to
be connecting so much right now people
can relate to his comedy and they relate
to there and he's not a joke teller he's
a storyteller yeah and i think people
sense what he's telling them is really
happening too and it is i see a dead
horse
just laid out in this guy's yard nate
bar bargetsi's humor reminds us that
we're all probably a little more
clueless than we'd like to admit
so i learned that horses
lay down to sleep
i did not know that and that's
okay
where are you trying to go
your i guess ultimate goal would be like
when people talk about like because i
mean it's hard to narrow and be like one
person's like the greatest there's you
know prior chappelle carl and seinfeld
you get all these kind of names burr
uh but you just want to be mentioned i
think with
uh
with the people at the top like that's
that's the ultimate
goal that i think for me is a stand-up
so so nate's one of the funniest and one
of my favorite people to have on tv in
my household he was a very soothing and
hilarious presence through the
coronavirus lockdowns uh and so it was
thrilling for me to be able to introduce
him to a wider audience but i i thank
you for the introduction both you guys
knew who he was i had never heard of him
before it reminds me of sebastian
manoskalco i like humor that's relatable
that's funny yeah and clean and i just
think i love his delivery yeah i'm now
going to look at the netflix stuff yeah
go back to it everyone should tennessee
kids tony there's nothing like relatable
comedy be right we'll be right back